we have a new fallen movie not like
fallen movie but fallen movie though
following Denzel was sweet this is not
that angel has fallen so angel has
fallen as the new movie in the fallen
trilogy which is now a trilogy Olympus
has fallen London has fallen angel has
fallen angel has fallen Morgan Freeman
still plays the president but since they
probably charge by the line he's just
thinking about the plot it does sound
like 90s nonsense which is what these
movies are supposed to be is cheesy 90s
action movie nonsense the plot is the
president has been attacked he's in a
coma his lead Secret Service agent has
been framed for the crime now he's on
the run while he's trying to clear his
name that kind of has that fugitive vibe
if the fugitive wanted to be a cheesy
90s action movie and when it tries to be
like a fugitive the movies okay but when
it commits to the fact that it's a
sequel to Olympus has fallen then it
actually is pretty sweet like the
fugitive though it came out in the 90s
wasn't cheesy 90s action movie like the
fugitive was going for an Oscar was a
manhunt movie but to be that you have to
have finesse subtlety this has all of
the subtlety of Dolph Lundgren swinging
a sledgehammer in the 90s during a knife
fight like there's this one reveal that
happens maybe I've seen too much maybe
I've just I watched too many movies but
I didn't think they were trying to hide
this reveal until it was a reveal it's
like wait we weren't supposed to know
that so whether it's blatantly obvious
moments like that pluck for the
vice-president was like we believe the
Russians are behind this just like they
are behind the election tampering like I
don't remember him looking right at the
screen when he said that but he might as
[ __ ] well have been but for what this
movie is going for and by the third
movie what we know it's supposed to be
the movies service ibly entertaining
even does have that deeper theme which
I've seen a lot more of these days like
in the past year or two I've seen this
theme crop up in action movie franchises
or action movies in general where the
action guys getting older and he's
starting to face his mortality but he
knows that Fighting's all I'm good for I
mean yeah Metal Gear Solid did it before
it was cool but I've just seen it more
and more in this movie actually does
deal with that Nick Nolte's in this
movie briefly is like does he know he's
being filmed there's a part of me of the
things they were just like they found
him while they were filming something
they were like he's great but he always
plays this kind
roll now it's like he's that crazy old
guy who lives in the woods and if he's
not actually living in the woods his
character he still looks like he's from
mountain men season 78 or something let
us see Nick Nolte be like the new Bond
why not I still got it he was awesome
though and he was actually kind of
hilarious and he added something really
good to this movie but in the last act
of this movie it's like they were like
okay let's do some crazy action movie
stuff because hey we are Olympus has
fallen part 3 I always say that because
London is falling wasn't too crazy about
so when they commit to that it's a lot
of fun like that last act was actually a
pretty kick-ass last act it's ridiculous
like the word when we're all coming out
of the screening we're like it was
ridiculous right ridiculous take that
how you will some people meant it as a
positive and a negative but ridiculous
is the term whereas Olympus has fallen
was what diehard v should have been
angel has fallen is a ridiculous version
of the fugitive if the fugitive slammed
a Hulk Hogan energy drink from 1989 and
went to town subtlety no nuance um but
if you've enjoyed the Gerard Butler
fallen movies up to now I think you'll
enjoy those ones some of the CGI still
[ __ ] though it's like Olympus has fallen
London has fallen angel has fallen the
thing they have in common other than
Gerard Butler and Morgan Freeman
it's just subpar CGI it's like the
vision of these movies is always bigger
than their budget allows for you even
see it in the trailer it's like yeah
that looks just like that in the movie
you know how when the trailer has bad
CGI people are like they're gonna clean
it up in two months no they usually
don't and that in the movie looks just
as green-screen as it looks there it's
serviceable enjoyable I think it's more
enjoyable if you're a bit drunk yeah and
now it's a party way the same rating you
gave London has fallen that's true that
is the same rating but that's worth that
rating kind of shifts it's like there's
a positive spectrum and a negative
spectrum London has fallen I mean as the
negative spectrum that's what I mean is
more positive it's a french together go
to the theater uber because you got to
be responsible but have a couple drinks
you'll have some fun all right so angel
has fallen have you seen it what do you
think about it or what's your favorite
manhunt ish movie whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to say more
[Music]